PETA they are in the news once again
they're in the news like every other
month for something bizarre happening
this time it's about a billboard that
they had put up in England let's take a
look somebody the fluids are bad for you
don't swallow ditch dairy it appears
that that woman has been [ __ ] on guys
aren't clear its milk is milk right milk
jizz whatever the point is they took
that ad down in 48 hours people were
very upset about it they said it was
just this was pushing it a bit much
we've got a quote from the director of
PETA the billboard is a cheeky way to
alert passers-by to the dangers of
drinking cow's milk dairy products wreak
havoc on human health and the dairy
industry is routine cruelty to cows were
used as nothing more than milk machines
should persuade anyone not to swallow
products made with cows milk
I think the swallow of air was sort of
icky
I think this is kind of interesting
because there's probably some scientific
points to be won maybe about dairy and
humans maybe I mean people yeah
technically everyone is lactose
intolerant you just build up you know
immunity to it but the thing is is like
they're their right to a degree that
that the cruelty that goes on with cows
in the dairy industry is terrible it
really is so I understand that they're
trying to make that point with this it's
just so like but honestly it's working
people are talking about it that's what
they wanted to happen a lot of groups do
this they'll make a billboard or send
some kind of message that's over-the-top
controversial people talk about it
because if you say something nicely no
one listens to you right so is that the
key here so they're just playing us sort
of like they know this is over the top
because this is purely porn sexual we
get what they're doing and then they
take it down and now they just get free
advertising
I mean yeah I mean this is old hat for
PETA I generally disagree with 99% of
what PETA says I also generally disagree
with maybe 50% of PETA's marketing
tactics I love this one I gotta be
honest I think it's
larious I get that a community would
want to take it down that's their
prerogative to put pressure on the
Billboard company to have never put it
up you know that's a different
conversation altogether but I think it's
funny I don't know what else to say
about it except it's funny and also
really if if the argument that's made is
that your concern that your kids are
gonna see it and they're not ready to
see something like that or they're gonna
be you know it's a parent's trying to
protect their children
I personally don't think kids would get
it I was gonna say right but they don't
get that reference act like a kid either
is going to not get it in which case you
can sort of say something that will you
know satisfy that yeah knowing you just
don't go into the double entendre you
just stick to the single writing I've
got splash with exactly and there's
nobody wants milk in their face right do
you think this is sort of what we were
talking about with the previous segment
and Grand Theft Auto but does PETA end
up strengthening the other people
because then and this is also what
you're saying that they're just they
throw these things out and the people
are the animal rights people see there
oh yeah yeah I mean this is a tough one
because I feel like that with a lot of
different groups like recently American
atheist put out a very controversial but
we did that last week and you know
people are saying the same thing isn't
it strengthening the opposite side and
to a degree it is but then if you keep
putting out messages like that whenever
you do come back a little bit and you
are more conservative on your stance
people see it as more acceptable because
they've already seen something far worse
and I feel that way about this billboard
this is tame for PETA I mean this isn't
throwing blood on a you know somebody
wearing fur in public this is really
famous term on someone's face it's a
picture you know what I mean it's an
advertisement I'm it's fine
yeah it's tame alright well the ad was
taken down we've talked about it what do
you guys think let us know in the
comments right down below